استعاده اذا قوته الامن البرازيليه
السيطره على القصر الرئاسي ومقريه برلمان
والمحكمه العليا في اول حدث من نوعه منذ
40 عاما وقد استدعت جهود اخلاء المقار
السياسيه من المحتجين اللجوء الى القوات
الفيدراليه بامر من الرئيس لولا دا سيلفا
كما اعلنت الشرطه استدعائها قوات اضافيه
من ولايه عده لدعم قوه الامن في العاصمه
بينما تسلمت الشرطه الفيدراليه تحقيقه في
الاحداث
هذا هو توعد الرئيس البرازيلي لولا دا
سيلفا المشاركينا في اقتحام المؤسسات
العامه بالمحاسبه ووصفهم بالناظرين
والفاشلين واقال في بث على تويترنا
الجامعه يعرفون الديمقراطيه وجدت لحمايه
حق التعبير ولديها الياتها لحمايه المؤسسه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ليعرف جيدا ان الديمقراطيه التي وجدت
لحمايه حق التعبير لديها الياتها لحمايه
مؤسساتها التي تصون الديمقراطيه من
اقتحموا مؤسساتنا الشرعيه هم ناسيون
وفاشيون متطرفون فعلو ما لم يشهدوا تاريخ
بلدنا
بدوره وصف وزير الداخليه والعدل
البرازيليه فلافيو دينو والاحداث التي مرت
بها البرازيل في الساعات الماضيه لانها
محاوله انقلاب فاشله وقال الوزير انه تم
اعتقال ما يقرب من 200 شخص حتى الان
والاعتقالات مستمره
والديمقراطيه يؤكد ان الامر لا يتعلق
بالانتخابات هذا ارهاب ونحن على يقين من
ان الغالبيه العظمى من البرازيليين لا
يريدون تنفيذ هذا النوع من الظلام في
حياتهم نقوم باحصاء الاضرار التي حدثت في
السلطات الثلاث للجمهوريه لدينا ما يقرب
من 200 معتقل في جريمه تلبس والاعتقالات
مستمره
في المقابل رفض الرئيس البرازيلي السابق
جايين بورسونارولتهامات التي وجهها له
الرئيس لولا دا سيلفا والمتعلق باقتحام
مباني حكوميه في العاصمه برازيليه وقال
بورسونار في تغريده ان المظاهرات السلميه
جزء من الديمقراطيه لكنها اقتحام المباني
العامه يمثل تجاوزه
معنا من امام القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه
برازيليا مراسل الجزيره حسان مسعود حسان
اهلا بك اذا استنفار كبير في البرازيل
واعتقالات ايضا في هذا البلد على خلفيه ما
حصل امس ما تفاصيل
نعم يا سفيان تجاوز عدد من تم اعتقالهم من
المحتجين الذين اقتحموا هذه الساحه ساحه
السلطات الثلاثه وسط العاصمه البرازيليه
ومقار الحكم الثلاث مقر القصر الرئاسي قصر
البلنالدو مركز الحكم في البرازيل
ومقر ومبنى البرلمان وكذلك
المحكمه الدستوريه العليا في البرازيل عدد
مئتي شخص على الاقل حتى هذه اللحظه وفقه
ما اعلن عنه وزير الداخليه والقضاء في
البرازيل ما زالت همم القوات الامنيه تفرض
سترتها بشكل كامل وتغلق هذه المنطقه وسط
العاصمه سنشاهد هذه الاوضاع هنا في
العاصمه همم الان هنا خلفي تماما القصر
الرئاسي الذي تشاهدونه الان همم تظهر لكم
همم الصوره اثار الدمار
خراب الذي حل بالقصر الرئاسي بعد هذا
الاقتحام الذي همم كان قد حدث خلال همم
اليوم الماضي بمشاركه الاف من مؤيدين
الرئيس السابق جرير بورسونارول الذين
دخلوا الى هذا القصر حطموا الزجاج حطموا
المحتويات همم
عبثوا بمحتوياته ومقتنيات هذا القصر قبل
ان تتمكن القوات الامنيه من استعاده
السيطره على القصر بشكل كامل فيما تجري في
هذه اللحظات تحقيقاتها وتدير هذه
التحقيقات الشرطه الفدراليه بشكل خاص بعد
ما كان الرئيس لولا ده سيلفا الذي كان قد
زار القصر قبل همم ساعتين تقريبا بعد
عودته من ولايه سوف لم يكن
في القصر الرئاسيه عندما تم هذا الاقتحام
الرئيس لولا دا سيلفا كان قد امر
بتدخل الفيدرالي من قبل القوات الامنيه
الفيدراليه بضبط الامن هنا في العاصمه
برازيليا همم وبدات بالفعل الشرطه
الفدراليه اجراء تحقيقات داخل القصر كنا
نتابع قبل قليل عمليات همم
حصر الاضرار داخل القصر
ومتابعه همم رصد همم حجم الدمار الذي حل
بهذا المبنى الحكوميه الرمزي الذي تدار
منه همم البلاد وكذلك حتى هذه اللحظه ما
زالت القوات الامنيه همم في هذه المنطقه
ااه تتواجد تغلق همم
الشوارع المؤديه الى هذه الساحه همم ساحه
السلطات الثلاث همم ستراتها بشكل نكمل
فيما همم ايضا تم استخدام تعزيزات امنيه
من مختلف المدن والولايات البرازيليه
الاساسيه من الشرطه الفيدراليه والقوات
الفيدراليه الى هنا الى العاصمه الفدراليه
لبطسط الامن همم في هذه المنطقه وعدم
تكرار هذه المشاهد والاحداث كما قال همم
الرئيس او وزير الداخليه والقضاء ااه
البرازيلي في اخر التصريحاته عندما قال ان
ما حدث في البرازيل همم لم يتكرر على
الاطلاق نشاهد اثار همم هذه
المواجهات ايضا التي حدثت بين همم
المحتاجين وقوات الامن همم عند محاونتهم
لفضل همم التظاهرات التي كانت همم في هذه
المنطقه والاحتجاجات همم الغاز المسيل
للدموع وكذلك
ابي الرصاص المطاطي في محاوله لفضل هذه
الاحتجاجات التي كانت بالالاف لمؤيدين
الرئيس
جرير بولسنارو الرئيس الرئيس السابق الذي
بالمناسبه هو خارج البلاد
خرج قبل يوم من تنصيب الرئيس لولا دا
سيلفا هنا في هذا القصر في الاول من يناير
الماضي الى العاصمه الى مدينه
ميامي تحديدا الى فلوريدا في الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه وهمم لم يسلم همم اشاره
الرئاسيه همم
الرئيس السابق او الرئيس الذي تم تنصيبه
لولا ده سيلفا وهمم همم حتى لم يهنئ
الرئيس لولا ده سيلفا بفوزه بهذه
الانتخابات اذا المشهد ما زال مستمرا هذه
بعض همم الاثار للرصاص المطاطي وكذلك
للخرطوش الذي كان يستخدم هنا همم للغاز
المسيء للدموع الذي تمكنت من خلاله القوات
الامنيه من بصي سيطرتها وافراغ هذه الساحه
بهذا الشكل مسعود